what's up everybody at Santa Mack and
welcome to another installment of the
week's best anime videos where you can
come to catch up on all the good stuff
that you miss the week before the links
told the videos that we mentioned are
right there in the description and if
you have a recommendation for next week
just leave it in the comments just some
quick news this Tuesday at 7 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time we're gonna be
hosting our very first live stream right
here on YouTube Tuesday is election day
in the United States and while everyone
else is talking about Trump and Clinton
we're gonna be talking about which anime
character would make the best president
we invite you guys to come join us we're
gonna have special guests we're gonna be
taking your questions and we're gonna be
talking about our favorite anime
characters now as we mentioned in last
week's episode
Aki Dearest arrived in Japan this week
and in the beginning of the week she
made a few videos with Joey
- anime man but then on Friday Joey
uploaded a video on his channel together
with Aki in which he confirmed that the
two of them are dating they have been
officially dating for about four months
and many fans already knew it but now we
have official confirmation the ship has
sailed
on her channel aki uploaded a second
longer video in which she enjoyed talk
about their relationship in greater
detail personally I'm really happy for
these guys I wish them all the best
in fact Joey and Aki are a real anime
youtuber power couple now and I think
they're second only to noble senpai and
his fictional girlfriends uploaded a
really funny video called re0 in 8
minutes in which he summarizes that
whole anime in 8 minutes in a hilarious
way he has made videos like this before
including Tokyo ghoul in five minutes
and they're always so well done and
really funny
you cook uses really good voice actors
for these videos the editing is really
well done and just in general the videos
are a must watch there are some spoilers
in this video but so much or easier has
become a meme by not that you might not
even notice and whether you've seen re0
or not you will definitely laugh out
loud if you watch this video check it
out for sure on monday digi bro uploaded
a video called cool character designs
Gurren Lagann in which he gives a
thoughtful analysis of the style and art
of the Gurren Lagann characters Gurren
Lagann is one of my personal favorite
animes of all time because I just love
the philosophy behind it and I love the
kameena so I definitely enjoyed this
video however it did tick me off that DG
bros pronunciation was way off in this
video I mean call me a weeb if you want
but it's not tanking toppa gurren lagaan
it's Tengen Toppa Gurren Lagann bob
samurai dropped a video this week called
top 10 long anime series in which he
counts down his favorite anime series
that are over 100 episodes long I found
this video very useful because I
personally am very skeptical of a long
anime anime were 100 episodes long to me
my favourite anime is tend to be between
12 to 50 or 60 episodes max and whenever
I hear that there's an anime that's over
a hundred souls long I start thinking
that it has a lot of filler that the
plot lines are probably convoluted and
things like that but I really need to
get rid of that personal bias that I
have against long anime because there
are long anime out there like Hajime no
Ippo and legend of the Galactic Heroes
there are absolutely worth watching and
I think Bob does a good job of pointing
this out for never world uploaded a
video this week called one of the
greatest anime ever monster in which he
reviews this epic anime I believe that
this video was originally made a few
years ago and that it's actually
re-upload but it's definitely worth a
watch monster is one of the finest anime
in the mystery and psychological horror
/ thriller genre and it is one of those
anime that's really memorable and sticks
with you especially because of Johan
Leibert who is the villain of the series
and one of the most memorable villains
in all of anime if you're a fan of
monster definitely check out this review
and if you haven't seen monster yet but
you are looking for a really dark and
mature anime definitely watch this one
finally a youtuber named warlocks MV
uploaded on a MV this week about the
anime the devil is a part-timer this amv
is really top quality stuff and I found
a really interesting because it portrays
the anime in a much more serious and
dark tone that it actually is the anime
itself is actually a comedy and in many
ways a parody of other fantasy anime
definitely check out this video and I'm
gonna keep an eye on warlocks amv
because it looks like his work is really
top-notch that's it for this week guys
if you enjoyed these videos be sure to
LIKE and subscribe and until next time
see you space Cowboys